one comment to make before i start today  you may remember i got criticized for  calling putin the war criminal  or the truth of the matter to show what  happened to rufus  this warrants him he is a war criminal  but we have to gather the information we  have to continue to provide ukraine with  the weapons they need to continue the  fight  and we have to gather all the detail so  this could be an actual have a war crime  trial this guy is brutal and what's  happening in bucca is outrageous and  everyone's seen it  no i think it is a war  on crime i'm seeking more sanctions yes  i'll have time to announce that  he should be held accountable  i don't know go go  the war crime trap yes i'm going to  continue to add sanctions thank you  i'll let you know